Eponine screws
the first of three spirits will come
soon I wanna clock strikes midnight the
next become the next night at the same
hour and the third will come the
following night also as midnight
[Music]
payees Australian actor Guy Pearce is
the latest in a long line of performers
to portray Evan easer Scrooge this time
the BBC FX version of A Christmas Carol
which airs on Christmas Day everyone
knows how screwed has changed so the
events in Charles Dickens classic story
but what's less well known is how the
book changed the celebration of
Christmas itself changes that cross the
Atlantic from England and are still with
us today
MTS taya takes us to London to find out
more the bright lights of London are
turned all the way up during the holiday
season with the British capital's
ancient streets crammed full of shoppers
buying gifts for loved ones a few here
might realise that it was the man who
lived at this house we inspired some of
our best loved holiday traditions
Charles Dickens yes the legendary author
of The Adventures of Oliver Twist great
expectations and a Christmas carol where
you didn't holiday classic that
introduced the world to Ebenezer scroo
[Music]
and of course his famous grumble humbug
bah humbug okay but what's less
well-known is what inspired the author
to write it the consider Schachter Simon
Callow perform Dickens for screen and
stage explains the tale started out as a
political pamphlet highlighting the
horrors of poverty in industrial era
Victorian England then suddenly had this
inspiration he would write not a piece
about someone who was poor but about
someone who was rich about a terrible
miser someone who lived entirely for
money at Bernie's ruin ever needs a
Scrooge the very same Bob Cratchit yes
most of us know Scrooge gives up his
selfish ways it's mr. Applegate sir he's
here to speak to you about his mortgage
god bless us
babish is a delectable dinner on the
family of his long
employee Bob Cratchit but it's Dickens
vivid description of delicious food
holiday decorations and goodwill to all
men not the curator of the Dickens
Museum Louisa Price says has become
something of a blueprint for how
Christmas is celebrated over a hundred
years after the author's death what's
really interesting about Charles Dickens
is we have to remember Christmas was not
celebrated in the way that we do now
yeah what Dickens did with the Carroll
and his subsequent Christmas writings
was really establish it as a significant
festival within the country and
something that everyone would celebrate
the commercial appeal of a Christmas
story was also not lost on Dickens one
of the reasons that it's so successful
is simply because it's seasonal you know
and that was one of the reasons he wrote
it he wrote it because he wanted it to
be very successful
although Dickens eventually tired of his
association with the holiday a Christmas
carols message of redemption continues
to be a gift that keeps on giving what
do you think he would make about the
enduring legacy of this I don't think
he'd be at all surprised he was fully
aware of the excellence of the Perkins's
so excellent Christmas celebrations
today wouldn't be the same if it weren't
for Charles Dickens
[Music]
for CBS this morning Saturday in pierced
high of London guy Pierce seems like a
really close I love my love wait to see
it I prefer Bill Murray but I'll give it
a shot yeah that's what I love though -
I mean I know this is about the
traditions but so many different
Scrooge's we saw the Muppet version I
love Scrooged with Bill Murray you have
the classic it's never ever gets old it
never gets all nor do the tradition all
of the movies stare it in
you